a controversial new law in California is
at the center of a brutal murder case a
couple was asleep in their bed when they
were stabbed to death nearly six years
ago now the surprising tip led to the
arrest of the then 15 year old Daniel
March he was convicted and sentenced to
52 years to life now a new law might set
this young man free when he turns 25 the
family of his victims is determined to
keep him behind bars bars Erin Moriarty
is following the case for this week's 48
hours it was the most horrific depraved
murder I've ever seen Yolo County
District Attorney Jeff ricing says the
stabbing deaths of chip Northup and
Claudia Maupin terrified the college
town of Davis California especially when
the killers seemed to vanish into thin
air
I was certain that they were gonna find
some forensic evidence in the crime
scene they found nothing
the case went unsolved for two months
and then police got a tip from a
teenager what are you reporting his best
friend Daniel Marsh was bragging about
killing the couple investigators brought
Marsh in you were there the high school
student denied all knowledge of the
murders but after over three hours of
questioning the facade began to crumble
Marsh admitted that for years he had
fantasized about killing the night of
the murders Marsh says he was hunting
for someone to kill and came upon chip
and Claudia's open window I got on the
screen climbed into the back he promised
he enjoyed stabbing them though
and Daniel thought he'd get away with it
taping the bottom of his shoes so he
wouldn't leave prints and wearing gloves
hidden at his home police found the
knife he used just 15 at the time of the
murders prosecutors charged Marsh as an
adult he was convicted and sentenced to
52 years to life but just four years
later a new California law was passed to
protect juveniles from being tried as
adults and that might set Marsh free on
his 25th birthday defense expert
psychiatrist Mattie Soulier believes
Marsh deserves a second chance I don't
think he's worth throwing away in my
opinion but chip and Claudia's family is
determined to do whatever they can to
keep Marsh behind bars Aaron good
morning I see why the families fighting
so hard his words are very chilling and
disturbing I know someone so young to
have such evil thoughts well because he
has actually been diagnosed as a
psychopath but the thing is this was six
years ago and Daniel Marsh and his
attorneys say he had a immature mind
he's now 21
he's changed what happens now to
determine whether he stays in prison or
not well the big question is whether his
case will fall under this new law and
the new law basically says anyone under
the age of 16 can never be tried as an
adult and in most cases I think that's
probably right but we've looked at there
are a handful of cases including Daniel
Marsh that the big question is can
someone like that be rehabilitated right
I mean he if you're a psychopath and he
scored one of the highest scores that
the psychiatrist's I spoke to had ever
seen at that age it's lack of empathy
it's it's like you know psychological
liars pathological liars
did you change even as you get older he
says he has you know what evidence do
they have though that he's changed
that's I'm still haunted by the words
that it was amazing to kill someone that
he doesn't even know and you haven't
seen the entire confession the entire
confession in fact some
the cop to listen to it we're damaged
just by hearing his words without even
seen any of the pictures Wow hey Darren
thank you very much you can see Aaron's
full report it's called portrait of a
killer on 48 hours that's tomorrow night
at 10:00 9:00 at ten o'clock nine
central right here on CBS